the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to ultimate
moves we're 10 of the best chess players
in the world and a couple of motivated
amateurs will team up in a way that you
have never seen before with a little
trash talking thrown in i'm grandmaster
maurice ashley and it is a pleasure to
welcome you to the world famous st louis
chess club it'll be an entertaining day
for sure as we have some of the top
players in a legendary name added in
let's take a look at the teams beginning
with team rex
we've got rexingfield captaining the
team of course world number two fabiano
caruana who lives here in saint louis
joined by lavon aronian lanier dominguez
peter svidler the eight-time russian
champion and of course
the legendary gary kasparov for team
mike we have mike lucan who will be here
replacing randy singh field who is
usually the player he will be the
captain of the team we also have maxim
vashila grav who recently won the
singfield cup along with grand chess
tour winner for 2021 wesley so hikaru
nakamura shakira mahmoud and sam
shanklin the format is four games will
be played at the time control of 10
minutes with a five second increment and
after five moves both teams will rotate
players that's going to be the key the
fact that the players will play for five
moves and then another group will tag in
and play for five as well should be an
amazing event joining us now is world
number two fabiano caruana and fabi
you've played in this event before
it's usually a lot of fun
how much does your team want to win
uh i think we want to win a lot it's uh
rex's team and i think rex is motivated
all of us are motivated so and it's
always a lot of fun
so yeah how do you appreciate the trash
talking element of this some some guys
here are legendary for their trash
talking skills
um yeah i'm looking forward to what
levon has to say
so we'll see um yeah it's uh
chess players are kind of quiet i guess
but sometimes their
trash talking nature comes through i
feel like chess players generally are
not so quiet off camera like a lot of a
lot of trash talking seems to happen
between you guys when you're just
hanging out that's that's true yeah
we're a lot more polite when when the
cameras are watching us
all right you also have one gary
kasparov on your team he's known not to
trash talk too much and matter of fact
he's usually the most intense of
everyone here what is it like to have
him on the team knowing that he wants to
win probably more than anybody else
well gary trash talks with his
expressions so he you can tell what he's
thinking he doesn't uh
he doesn't hide uh
hide what he's feeling especially
when someone makes a bad move or a move
that he disapproves of so
um
i think that's one of the things that
that rex and randy when he was playing
in the past they were both afraid of
gary's wrath you know
his judgment of their moves
and you mentioned lavonne
he stands out somehow special as a trash
talker tell me a little bit more about
him
yeah he's uh he's an excellent trash
talker i think he has a lot of
experience
um
and he also has the personality where he
doesn't
doesn't mind messing with people a bit
so
all right well thanks so much we look
forward to the battle
all right we will be starting shortly
again the mention that levon aronian is
such a great trash talker but i think
there's others who are more quiet we get
somebody like a wesley soul for example
who
loves to throw his words in but you just
you wouldn't suspect it because he's so
quiet normally but
he brings that as well
we're going to get organized we're going
to get the players in place and we'll be
back shortly for ultimate moves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello once again everyone two ultimate
moves 2021 and we are with
two of the competitors
trash talking competitors no doubt i
have rexingfield
everybody knows rex of course but mike
is new to the show mike luken a good
buddy and i'm going to start with you
mike
i know you're new we've seen this event
before what are your feelings about
replacing randy and going against your
good buddy rex well i was talking to uh
gary kasparov over lunch
and uh he thought that i would be an
improvement to the team he really wanted
to get rex replaced but he's comfortable
with me
all right the trash talking begins right
away rakes your feelings on not having
your son here and this time your good
buddy mike yeah well he's in the barge
business and i think he should go back
and jump in the river
[Music]
who who wins between the two of you guys
when you play i know you play a lot
online
what our mood is if i'm in a kindly mood
he wins
if i'm not then it's the other way how
do you feel about that
you know
i made one bad move about eight times
and those are the games he won
all right looks like the trash talking
has begun we're going to let the
competitors go take their seats and
we're about to start game one
and while we do that we're let's get
let's get someone over here
lavone may i may i get you please
grandmaster levon aronian lavone you've
played in this before
it's the one event that the top players
get to show their personalities directly
by being able to talk how do you feel
about this format is it to your
advantage
it's a lot of fun for me personally and
uh not so much fun for the people who
are not used to my uh
trash talking
mastery i would say you know i come out
of brooklyn where we do a lot of trash
talking in the parks
do you feel there should be a world
championship where players can play and
trash talk at the same time
i think most of the people understand
how good i am at this and they don't
they just don't want to you know be on
the losing side
all right indeed well you see it has
begun the fun has begun the players are
going to get seated again quite shortly
we have international arbiters in charge
of brian yang
and david hayder and uh i think rex is
just gonna get seated any second peter
if you don't mind
come on over we've got peter spidler
who's usually a co-commentator here but
lately has been a player peter your
feelings about playing in this kind of
event i'm well i'm going to be making
moves directly before gary
so i already dislike this intensely
i
have a feeling i have a feeling i'm
going to be in a lot of trouble later
today but uh apart from that it's a very
fun event and uh yeah levon levon said
all that needed to be said we're all
here just to watch live on
be mean to people and uh
i'm on the same team with him so maybe
i'm slightly covered but even that
doesn't really save you from
from anything really these days what you
feeling about just we talk about trash
talking
who is a surprise trash talker somebody
you say wait a minute he does he talks
like that
i think wesley has been expanding into
this field a little bit i've i've seen
some of his recent press conferences and
uh
uh i think he's spreading his wings uh a
bit in that direction and
whenever something that happens you you
you feel kind of stunned because
that's not what
what you expect from from from wesley in
particular but i think people people
have been doing this for years so people
have been sort of gradually improving
and you can you can expect you can
expect some barbs from
most people here all right well let's
look forward to it as the game's
about to begin
let's get to the table
and uh they're already talking to each
other at the board
and
they did the drawing up lots beforehand
so mike has the white pieces rex will
start with the black pieces again it's
four games
10 minutes per move with a five second
increment gentlemen you may begin the
games
and the games are underway
uh mike you guys like five moves
oh i thought we just played five moves
there we go all right we got in two free
moves two free moves yeah oh and it
looks like
uh you gotta hit your car you gotta hit
your car a lot oh the amateurs
haven't been playing too much live chess
in a while they're used to playing
online and lost some of some of the
skills the moves are good
and i believe white has played the fifth
move and now i'm gonna get up and rex
it's your turn
you get one more move
and there we go and now
for the time with
bobby poppy that comes in next bobby
where is
his clock is ticking
after that last one
and
they are already intense
lavon your thoughts on the position so
far
uh i think uh
black has a
positional advantage
because
we are from saint louis so
other than that uh
i like her position and i like the way
fabian plays chess i mean it's always
not not his not his moves but his
manners
are slow and
reserved
you sure you're not distracting him by
telling him all that all right no he
knows
all right well they do look intense as
this last move queen a5
has
suggested the exchange of queens and
also
he's thinking about the chickens and the
eggs
i'm the chicken
and he traded and now it is time for a
new duo to come down and it is
wesley
and lavon aronian fabi you just played
five moves your feelings about what
position you passed on to lavon yeah i'm
glad that uh maxime chickened out i know
he wanted to take on e7 but
uh
but he probably took his team and wind
when he didn't
are you saying he punked out
yeah yeah exactly
and the players are also talking to each
other let's get
another opinion sam shanklin sam you're
new to this event right it's your first
time ever playing in ultimate moves your
thoughts about playing and what you've
seen so far well let's be real i'm
probably not going to play just because
we're going to win before it's my turn
there's only like 15 moves left and
we're just going to give checkmate by
but uh yeah i guess we'll see i'm not
much of a trash talker but uh
that was pretty much i'm trash talking
also got everybody's attention yep
you're doing okay so far but
realistically yeah this game's going to
go in other 15 moves so i will have to
play
all right it definitely is a sharp
position
right now and lavon is in thought their
head on the clock is black and our
retreat knight back to b6 hikaru
it's been a while indeed uh since since
you won uh the rapping in blitz raven
and blitz
your thoughts about ultimate moves
it's a fun event actually this looks
like the most normal position i think in
out of all the games that i've seen very
solid no blunders from the inexperienced
players and i'm just playing a middle
game
looks looks very balanced but i think
we're doing well we have knights in the
center
you feel this you feel it's going to you
think it's going to come down to
uh the end game yeah well we're already
in we're already in game
i'm in a deep end game but yeah it's
touched
yes sir all right now hikaru has come
down and lanier dominguez
these two battle in the u.s
championships
and they're also teammates
for the olympic team this position
definitely is
very very solid as hikaru said
wesley
you didn't have too much difficulty in
this
having to decide what to do in this
position it seemed very solid
straightforward yeah that's true when i
sat on the board uh the queens were
already traded so i was already at home
but uh
i figured we
we should put pressure on on on black in
this game
also be a nice welcoming for for the one
iranian
everybody wants to beat levon why does
everybody want to beat lavon so bad if
he's the new guy on the block
newcomer to the united states is lavon
just moved here as of yesterday
all right well we'll make it interesting
maxime i see you uh on see you here with
a soda
uh you're just relaxing i am i'm just
feeling i mean i i
you know completed my duty i left a
great position it was even improved
after that so i think we're on our way
to win
you think it's just automatic already
like
that big an advantage for white
i just see a pair of bishops and i'm
like
it cannot get better than that
all right well
we see
a deep think right now
by lanier black's
pieces
still need completion in some way as he
said the two bishops could be a factor
chakriar you have yet to sit down are
you anxious relaxed
just having fun yeah of course it's very
nice to be here
i enjoy and i'm waiting
moves when i will start to play
this position looks like a top level
game it doesn't look like a couple of
amateurs started the game so far a
really strong game
yeah it's really i mean normally maxim
start to play this game maxim played
with black every time this position but
he starts very dwight
and he
he i mean it's a big surprise i mean
when is that play with white this
right he definitely is going for the
solid play here so
again difficult position indeed we see
move last move was played knight to d7
and it is hikaru's turn and carver one
of the best blitz players on the planet
no question about that
but now he's trying to figure out what
to do
where's this gary casparo we gotta get
gary gary's watching from a distance i'm
gonna go ambush gary
gary
if i may the position that you guys have
right now looks like uh
looks like very solid uh what are your
feelings about your chances it seems
like the last move 97 i would just
discuss with leon i would rather put my
knight on a6
yeah i just had at least some you know
uh ideas to go night before so it's um
it's unbalanced position so um
[Music]
looks like black is okay but it's it's
dangerous because you know white has two
bishops and uh
you know
unless we can create some you know
threats uh on the queen side so we may
uh
be struggling you know
with unpleasant end game all right nice
e4 looking to play the move knight to e3
your thoughts about that one
but yeah as i said it's just this it's
it's a sharp so it's the hopefully we
but
now you should you should start
calculating things like g5 for instance
all right knight g5 is on the board
and i mean the room just got super quiet
as though everybody get
serious about the position suddenly
nope
six is probably a good move
because black has so many squares and
knights so you're giving up the two
bishops yeah fully but you'll have
compensation
the king goes on so solid so
why is bishop don't have much
space
coming into the to the other side
is maxim makes even they're starting to
feel like black is definitely better
here you're feeling
for sure yeah i mean if this uh you know
losers win
then
maybe
your thoughts laura
well
you know after all
uh saint louis has a lot of french
history and
he's contributing you know helping the
centralized team
all right well the two bishops now
definitely in
white's possession but those knights
looking very strong
and knight a knight can go to d5 the
king to f7 so
uh i think white will still maybe try
i'm thinking rook d4 is a natural move i
don't know it looks
like just to create some
some problems really nice and chakriar
and svidler have sat down
has been sitting there potentially
hanging for quite some time
and now they're calculating
yeah but anywhere isn't like go for b2
and at some point bishop f1 and your
hook on b5 is not never with e4 knights
will be two knights before yeah look f2
even
i don't really care
just to have this would be one or
two pictures
all right players are getting into
this game very complex great position
for them to be playing and the clock
ticking down now 537 for white
as chakra tries to figure out exactly
what he needs to do
does not want to
alter the position negatively of course
no one does and gary caspar will be
sitting down following
peter's fiddler so pressure there as
well
rex
you've been
you've been watching this
you guys started but this game has gone
way beyond what you could have supposed
uh yes it has i think white's really
confused
uh you're talking about shaq remember
there are forget the white pieces you
think he's confused i think the whole
team is
still going
mike
you dropped your five moves down but
this game
looks like it's on another level
there's no question about that uh
i like the fact that black's got the
double pawns and i do like the two
bishops so i'm comfortable with that
all right all right loading the weakness
and a pawn on b2
captured by peters fiddler ramping up
the tension in this game is that a
greedy pawn to capture
and
one pair of bishops now off the board
and a straightforward
trade of rooks now being offered on the
b line as it will be very difficult
to defend the knight on b6
this game has definitely changed
dramatically
shikaru did you like that capture on b2
by by
black yeah just i well i thought bishop
before was trying to make a draw a
little bit dry i thought bishop h3 and
e4 was kind of more interesting i mean i
think now it'll probably just be
simplify into some kind of draw i think
so it won't be super exciting
what do you think you think that the
complications will be simple enough once
the amateurs sit down
um i don't
i think it's probably easier to play for
white maybe because
pawns are fixed so you you only really
focus on the rook and the bishops may be
easier for white to play maybe for us
it's better but it should be a drawing
we'll see where we are in 10 moves
and
yari will be sitting down momentarily
let's
let's get that moment as sam shanklin
gets to play
against gary kasparov with a big
handshake there big moment for him
and gary's intensity is clear as sam now
plays bishop
to c2 trying to eject the knight from
the a4 square and gary's fighting spirit
is on full display already you can see
in his posture his intensity his focus
he wants to play the absolute best move
to maintain some chances for black but
that b-pawn looks like it will drop
no matter what
deep in the heart of the position but it
looks like it's going to go any second
so knight c3 played and quickly taking
on e2 with check
of course
see i'm trying to decide what is the
correct square is it f2 or f1
and he decided on f2 gary dropping back
and now the
pawn on b7 is not
quite hanging as the c2 bishop is
hanging at the moment
black
is up a pawn
and
frankly i don't see what's wrong with
the position the pawn
your thoughts about the position now
well after the last move now we're much
better white had to play bishop d3
in order to have the b5 uh hanging
so we won't be able to consolidate so
easily
now
i would like you're looking for some
money chance yes and now we're
trash talking uh
uh shankland so
he's definitely feeling the pressure
in the group
and
i like i'm looking at gary gary's foot
is shaking and he's so focused
do you do you know someone who's
displayed this kind of competitive
spirit and this guy's not even a chess
player anymore i mean
at least he's retired
no of course it's very special that
gary uh is ready to
do his best it doesn't matter where he
plays so
lovely
big move a4
on the board and now
the amateurs come in
and look at this moment where mike is
sitting down and gary gives him the
stare down on that last move gary gave
him a look and took the pawn
on a4 and rex comes in now we've seen a
lot of grandmaster move so far but will
they be able to keep up the quality of
play three minutes and 52 seconds left
on the clock for white 5 31 for black
and
white to move king
to e3
and now rex has retreated his light and
that could be problematic
problematic they get to play four more
moves
before the top players come in again and
a big time move knight bishop takes on
c6 the knight is now clearly hanging
and they are down two minutes on the
clock
but it looks like white's gonna recover
the material or maybe maybe not maybe
not make some precise moves
in order to keep this position alive
and wrecks with four more moves to make
mike with only three
deep in this endgame but it's all about
that pawn on a4
will it or won't it survive and he's
played his knight back
to c7 and allow the pawn to be captured
that has changed the
game looks like white is back
in the game completely
and
the best play
white [ __ ]
well it looks interesting as it is right
now under
three minutes on the clock black with a
significant time advantage now rook to
b5 is wesley so
this actually
jumps right he winds down the game i
mean
the game will continue and we probably
do get to move whichever it is
50 45 i can't come
but yeah rugby fight now allows 95 which
i think should make
what i assume is a comfortable draw it
doesn't look like bobby wants to play
the move
is he looking for an alternative it
looks like
that's the smart money move just to wind
down the game yeah
oh i don't think there is
i don't think there's much of a choice
on his fan
anything else would have put us in
severe danger i think
and now f4 is hanging so that piece must
be captured and it looks like we are
getting down
to
that equal position more trades
players are laughing now as they realize
that no one's going to blunder this kind
of end game anymore we'll probably see
more trades
[Laughter]
and there we go couple more trades check
and
wesley just trying to decide where to go
and e6 played
allowing a check that will win the
e-pawn but
will not be enough to win the
game that shouldn't be enough
depending on the move
and now white up upon for the moment and
hikaru trying to keep the game alive
somewhat
but it's pretty clear that this one
should i was trying to make the game as
long as possible
[Laughter]
yes they definitely wanted
since white is the one who is ahead
right now
we will see now with the clock ticking
down remember
rex and mike are still due to come in i
don't think we've ever seen
players come back a third time the
amateur players come back a third time
and here we see
white maintaining the game as much as
possible this is the new strategy
because white is the one who's ahead
so they're going to see whether or not
they could make the players suffer
enough
as gary comes
in next and after gary is done
we will see the amateurs come back will
they know how to win this or draw this
position it's really up to black to draw
the game it is definitely
a known drawn position grand masters
would
accept the draw but will rex be able to
follow
the lead and deal
in this position and here we go
mike is coming in gary is leaving and
this is where
the tension is at its highest
what will happen right now plenty of
time on the clock but this is a
well-known philidor's position and this
is the critical moment right now
and rex shows his mastery of this end
game bringing his rook all the way down
that is the key move they did not want
to see that move happen
there's still a few moves to go of
course but we'll see how rex handles the
rest
bobby your feelings about rex right now
is he looks like he's got it down pat we
can still win this
with black i love some hope
it looks it looks like uh
so mistaken the move there
seems to have this rex is showing this
down
without any question and we're seeing a
repetition as the checks are occurring
and i think
that's it uh
and i think that we're gonna just see a
repetition of moves and that's going to
end the game in a draw
an incredibly tense affair
yes uh they're going to call it a draw
to the player's amazing first game
other than one blip
where rex had a chance to to win a piece
mike you're feeling you you survive you
dodged the bullet where rex could have
forced your your piece and you're the
last time you take the bishop but you
know you know you got to consider who
you're playing against and play
accordingly
rex you're feeling about the first the
first tough game that was a draw what
are your thoughts
oh they got off lucky
my engine was running on one cylinder so
what do you expect you know
all right well indeed a very tense game
again with that one blip but very well
played
we're gonna come back in a few minutes
to start game two just in a moment stay
with us for ultimate moves 20 21.
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to game two of
ultimate moves 2021 the first game ended
in a draw
very interesting game there was one big
moment of course that black could have
won a piece but that moment passed and
the game was tense and ended up in a
rook and pawn standard draw we're gonna
start game two right now let's get
started this time rex has white and mike
has the black pieces
underway rex with e4 and these players
have played each other quite a bit
so they know each other's styles
and
we see
f4 quickly
and a little bit of hesitation there by
mike against
rex's moves we've got a fiance bishop
and this now rex's last
move to come and he's played g3 as well
uh
one more move for mike rex you can get
up
and knight f6 played while standing as
well
sure
that's
standard technique
and caruana coming in with maxine
vashila grav who's used to fianchettoing
his dark squared bishop
when he plays a grunfeld but not in a
sicilian normally he's
oh he just corrected me and said he's
played some dragons before
and games
pretty solid right now absolutely no
pawns touching no trades just yet
and again very slow play here by caruana
and b5 thrusting that pawn forward and
fabiano with his fifth move played and
here comes lavonne
the great key is to play with white
and now wesley's so
coming in as well
and
gary you're feeling about this position
so far levon said the great basket
played this with the ypc yes i think
he's recalling this pesky geller
uh quarterfinal match so spassky crushed
him by playing
playing
this this closed sicilian so it became
very fashionable
uh but uh it's something it's a
double-edged position that
white has you know
attacking opportunities so now it's uh
but but it's not again it's not easy
because because black also has very
strong bishop and
you know the plan for why did this okay
bring the queen on age four somehow
and then
just uh make make sure
and he's listening
you're feeling you're feeling if you had
to pick a side which one would you want
to be i think i would take one
at some point
that's a serious move he just played
stopping the queen from going to h4 yeah
i think that's maybe it was the only
only one
all right this one has definitely gotten
super sharp right away
one more for him
one more move
for both sides right now very rich
position gary look at look white the
both pawn structures just it's pure
aggression pent up the kind of
aggression you used to play with
yes yes
i still think white somehow is more
more
position is more entertaining
so we'll see what happens all right e4
now nakamura coming in
all right this this one
you must feel like you want to sit down
right now like
you jump in
it seems to me that you know when i when
i
take my my stand
there will be a lot of play
all right that will be some time
they they're quite serious because
there's nothing happens in the first
five moves
actually interesting positions and uh
yeah let's see what happens you know
late at the end later indeed high level
play
uh
let's see we've got let me on this side
i'd like to get somebody
playing black
maxim you started this position with the
black pieces right after
rex and mike got up yeah man
in you know a little bit of a dangerous
position but dangerous doesn't mean bad
i think we have pretty good chances here
like we look passive but
after passivity comes you know it's a
great awakening
the great awakening i've never heard
that term before
where did you come up with that one the
great awakening
might be warcraft
everybody's playing video games these
days
sam
you you gotta see the taste of it in the
first game if i can get you to come over
here in the first in the first game now
the second game seems like this is some
grandmaster like high-level chess it's
not just fun everybody's so serious yeah
it's it's getting messy um i don't love
our position honestly i think this
bringing our knight to c7 didn't strike
me as great i think we should have
played e6 in 97 or put the knight on d7
to take advantage of the dark scores but
there's a lot of fight left and uh
looking forward to playing again the
first game i got to sit across from my
childhood hero for the first time and
not give him a draw in the philidor
position so you know looking forward to
something similar but we'll see
isn't it pretty extraordinary to be
facing gary casparo i'll play him for
real soon enough uh so yeah it'll be fun
indeed we do have
a chess 9lx coming up after this event
chess 9lx
three days of extraordinary chess we're
getting all these original positions
chess 960 as it is more formally known
official random that would be coming up
tomorrow and the two days after that but
first
and please join us at 1 30 central time
for those uh that celebration
of
this new art form or relatively new form
that everyone's playing i'll be joined
by alejandro ramirez as well in the
commentary booth right now it's all
about these rich positions that we're
seeing here
and of e3
by peter svidler and shakaramaderov
sitting down
two superstars one from russia one from
azerbaijan
and a really incredibly rich position
i'd like to get fabiano's opinion if you
don't mind probably
you got to start all this
but now it's
getting good this is where the action is
i would say rex started it not not me
um
i i feel like i had the most boring task
out of all the players to make the
generic starting moves but now now it's
really
really exciting
it looks uh
looks good for us but
it's not easy
you say yes uh you have the white pieces
here
and a lot of space for white black's
getting counter play on the other side
how do you shut it down
i can't can't say anything
last move c4 tell that was best
um
i was wondering i
might not have been what i would go for
but
um
yeah i mean black needed the counter
play because on the king side it's just
it's very one-sided
basically it's
if black doesn't do something
then slowly gets rolled over on the k
side so he has to start
start some play
yeah chakra is the kind of player who
likes to play sharp chest
uh you feel he's suited for this this
task and last move
knight to b5 and then obviously
yeah i think black is
getting a more or less playable position
which i wasn't sure about
i came to bishop on g7 has more future
than the bishop on g2
a bold prediction why do you feel this
bishop on well your bishop ken thank you
for that
he just
he just overheard you and shut down any
bishop 86 opportunity
come coming later i you know it's a
great awakening doesn't come now but
in a matter of 20 30 moves maybe
we will keep our eye on the g7 bishop as
the mind of maxime is
in warcraft right now it's not just
necessarily or both at the same time
but the clock doesn't seem to be any
factor right now as they're both playing
fairly quickly white does have
less time uh for sure
but
enough time for bosun to be thinking
about this position we see shakur are
getting deep
into some ideas
we haven't spoken to you
have you been
enjoying it so far and what do you think
about this position yeah in general it's
always super fun this event and
so far we had interesting games very
fighting games interesting positions on
this one too i think
i mean i liked our chances previously
maybe we've done the last
10 months or so
we're not
as good as i was expecting but you guys
are playing the white pieces just to
remind the audience here
yeah but still looks like a very i mean
looks like decent chances for us and
i trust my team
we've been playing a lot of chess over
this summer
uh so far you've been playing a lot of
chess and now you get to play this as
well you're looking forward to chess 960
tomorrow yeah i'm looking forward to the
event i always enjoy the
960. it's very
nice game where you have to like think
from the start which i like in general
so i'm very much looking forward to it
all right we'll let you keep thinking
about this position
and
white
was way down on the clock but it looks
like
mike's been thinking quite a bit
about what to do next and
maybe surprisingly so
lavon
shakur has been deep in thought he had a
two-minute edge on the clock the time
has ticked down why is he taking so long
you have to
like come up with a plan
and
the position
will
mainly depend on the next couple of
moves
so
you want to try and find the most
precise way to put up some pressure
but i think we're doing we're doing okay
with white i cannot say that we're
better but
we're we're safe
so far he's just played a very
aggressive d5
a lot of tension also sacrificing
momentarily on the device
if this move was played
without any thought i would probably
think it's a blunder but since there was
so much time spent on it
it's probably a very interesting
idea
i think now suddenly everybody went
quiet
maybe both of london and an interesting
idea
this moves
and it works out
because
well
i'm not sure we're hearing your whispers
with the mic but let's let's uh move
away a little bit and get your get your
insides because i i think now we can
take on d5 and then take one g6 and play
bishop b4
and then quench it to
kind of protect the upon the bottom
before opponent yeah yeah but but it of
course a lot of defensive black can play
queen f7 and then rugby eight bishop is
only five i guess so
well
it's a tough
decision for peter to make as well
yes it's an interesting it's an
interesting concept d5
extreme sharpening of the game and who
goes after
peter will be gary will have the white
pieces
and sam will have the black pieces so
that matters as well sam i made
shaktaria just
antied up
uh the tension
with the move
d5 you're gonna have to play to follow
it are are you feeling comfortable with
him doing this i'm much more comfortable
with him doing that than sitting around
and waiting to die on the king side with
nothing happening i have a sharp game
and i'm looking forward to it are you
gonna have gary on the other side though
trying to kill you your thoughts being
down upon for the moment uh did he take
it yet no i mean if it happened oh uh
huh we'll see i don't think we're gonna
stay down upon i'm much more worried
about king safety than i am about the d5
pawn but we'll uh we'll see if i can
keep him safe all right it's gonna be
your turn momentarily
and
so now gary at five minutes
less than five minutes
and chakra are needing to decide
as peter did not capture the pawn peter
why didn't you take on
i didn't see this before in the end of
that line i was i didn't want to allow
bishop to seven with tempo i didn't see
a good follow-up but the fghd which
before may have been quite strong
uh i was
there's like three different directions
i could have taken after g5 and it's
difficult to choose one
there was a greedy way of playing queen
before because it actually wins the pawn
on v3
i think but
it gives it like time to develop some
initiative or i could have played just
g5 actually it's an interesting move on
every single move there so
this is it
it's an insane position yeah it's an
incredibly difficult position to play in
a fun position to play but yeah like
in this time control you just have to
take take a kind of a
gut decision i think in the inclusion of
bishop before request 7
keeps our options open
and
i thought it improves our position in
case we want to play g5 for instance so
i thought it was a decent choice but
yeah i'm pretty sure that
i didn't really get to the bottom of it
you also have to pay attention to the
clock because i don't think i can pass
this position on with two minutes on the
clocks
right absolutely well definitely
it's incredible how competitive these
first two games have been
and right now it is up to sam
as gary has played the super sharp g5
ramping up the pressure as black as
definitely under
all kinds of tension right now we see
pawn exchange as possible
a lot to think about if you've got the
black pieces right now and
slightly ahead of the clock and he's
played very quickly with knight to d4
again no exchanges look at gary's
look on his face just incredible the
intense glare
and focus that he went to the game and
dropping back his bishop to
pressuring
c3
knight on d4 of course but
still who's going to blink first who's
going to trade pond
how do you improve this position and
black bishop on c8 has not moved
the entire game so far
just sitting waiting in the wings when
will that piece come in the game and
will it
alter it
the position at all
i can tell you the tension is thick in
the room right now
players are trying to appreciate the
niceties of this incredibly complex
position and
note as well
that rex the two amateurs rex and mike
will be sitting down shortly
and we know anything could happen there
might seem this kind of position i mean
it's made better you're invited this is
the kind of thing you like to see happen
but the amateurs are going to sit down
in a complex position anything could
happen in that game
that's
that's what he wants i'm i'm i'm i've
always been a gambler so
you know that first hand
yes indeed
uh knight c2 on board your thoughts
about this move peter well sam is
clearly trying to play d5 before next
trying to shut down the the bishop on c3
and there is a lot of potential captures
on the nobody cares about the rook on a1
so there is a lot of things you can do
on the other side of the board now like
every gf gf followed by fg i don't know
which one is stronger you both have been
done yeah knowing that the question is
just of the order i think you always
play those two moves
and then you kind of wait for the reply
i think we're doing extremely well but
it's still a sharp position and
yeah the professional round is over
after this so
and you said nobody cares about europe
on a1 they like rand masters though but
but the amateurs are gonna love to say
they're wondering why you didn't take
the run
we'll see we'll see but like this is an
incredibly interesting position
i'm really enjoying this but
definitely an extraordinary game
something you could
literally
see a fatal look on
on fabiano's face fabi what's going on
why are you
no wait why not why not what
why not the whole game i don't know
i've already lost
like i had a sense of what was going on
and that completely evaporated
i offered to you for this to restore
some mud when we
play our moves
i want to ask you how do you feel about
the future of a bishop still optimistic
he made a prediction about the bishop on
g7 and now he doesn't seem to
be guns on buried
well
some people might argue that and death
is better than prison that's what you're
saying
that's what i'm saying
all right indeed well the time is
ticking down now we see 325 for white
and gary trying to figure out what his
next play should be black with 402. the
work on a1 has been hanging for some
time
but
as peter said no one's concerned about
giving you an exchange in such a sharp
position
bishop on c3 hanging
completely chaotic i don't know
there's a lot of things hanging
and maxine still has some hope for his
bishop
it seems to me though the position so
wild this is not the kind of position we
can judge just generally he's taking on
g7
and
after on c3 and that will get very
interesting now it is time for the
players to get off this
thing if there is a queen hanging will
rex first of all
hold on hold on because this rex's turn
with the white pieces
and his queen is hanging his queen is
hanging he's got to resolve that problem
first
he's got to get the zen of this position
he's only 218 on the clock
and at the moment his queen
is hanging
this is a huge moment in the game
will rex notice
and
this is this is and the clock is ticking
he's deciding either to take with the
queen on c3 with the pawn
he can see things hanging everywhere
he can also take on a seven first
lots of options right now for
white
and will they confuse him
as he only has 142
and he's moved his queen all the way to
g5 leaving the b2 pawn
and this one is just insane we don't
know what's going to happen there's no
even need to predict what's going on we
don't know it's just a question of how
the two players feel
uh
about the chaos that's in front of them
i think probably this is like an insane
you couldn't guess the next move black's
gonna play or white i i could try but uh
i didn't predict the last move but it's
not a battle
and mike's struggling with a big-time
advantage on the clock for black at the
moment
and he's traded
one that resolves one major issue very
good news for us
and now
threats coming brewing in the position
now rex has to decide he's taking the
ball on c3 that's giving the b-pawn the
chance to
scoot down the board
it's too sharp even for us
it's insane
totally
in the same position
mike
good friend of rex's they play all the
time together can he solve
this problem to get bracket rights
against his friend as this position is
so incredibly sharp
white has a pawn sitting on g7 black as
a pawn b3 that one threatening to
potentially
queen but white generating major threats
in the position as well but the clock
ticking down and we'll see the
the grand masters come in momentarily
bobby
these two guys standing in front of me
right now will be playing shortly so
they can't give away too much
information
about what they think about the position
and they're under attack and
was that rex's 15th
fourth move
go down
rex has to deal with his pawn oh what do
you think about the great awakening
well your bishop is too long dead
no i mean the general position and the
bishop on g2 also you know
is still buried in my opinion
yeah
all right we're up to b1 and rex it's
time to get up and bobby's going to get
up
i like to have one more move
and uh
in an incredibly tense moment as bobby
sits down and now
and now mike has to decide what to do
he's got fabiano caruana world number
two sitting across from him that's got
to be somewhat intimidating
and he's playing night
with a major attack and with force
hitting the clock
as well
what is white to do in this position
rook is hanging on
he's just playing queen takes e5
and allowed queen a7 jack a massive
blunder
magnitude
g6 was much better
he's just dropped
on
d1
it's not a bad thing
definitely a mistake by calling carolina
peter that was uh good news for you guys
i'm sorry you're sorry bad news
not the most stellar of news yeah i
think we're in trouble now
putting it mildly because there's just
no counter play and we're down of pull
rook and the fallen p2 is still alive so
yeah rexy should put some sense in
probably yeah fabiano made a horrific
throw there
i think after the quintessence the game
is still very much on i i was trying to
figure out if we're in that might
struggle even because
tonight the fight has a huge threat you
have to take on g7 when we go queen to
six check then we go knight to five
because the biggest problem is now that
the knight on g3 and the bishop g2 are
completely cut off by that one pawn on
g6 and taking it off the board would
have given us squares to attack exactly
exactly that's the problem
a big miss by the world number two and
now they're actually down to only
26 seconds is
still on the board that's not even the
real issue the fact is they're simply
donald rook at the moment and does white
have any compensation whatsoever is
there any tricks it looks like
it looks like nothing
anywhere and now he's down to only nine
seconds on the clock and he's throwing
in a queen e5 check
and it's going to be what seems to be
simple enough to just get the king out
of the way
and
black
should just be winning with no real
issues here
incredible mistake by bobby certainly
red face knowing that it was his fault
why they might lose
[Laughter]
i thought it was already over so i've
been
i don't know
what queen g6 is that actually
yeah
if i survive
the game very much continues yeah
just a really broadcast among the
pigeons
all right let's just let this game end
as
obviously
what the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
nobody's
clearly white is
completely dead but he did not have to
resign
and now linear poor lanier has to sit
with the black pieces can they last
nobody wants to resign
they want to give this position to
kasparov and
ouch that's nasty
and it looks like there it is an
exchange of queens lanier resigning
and
black was won the game team
mike with a win and again
bobby i've got to come back to you a
real error on your part
we would have
no no
no no not at all not at all it was not
your fault
what is this it's my fault
i thought the game was over
queen just like though maybe it's over
but
in the other direction i don't know
what are they gonna play queen g7 queen
is lost
but a new queen appeared on board still
still trying to justify the great
awakening well i mean your team
did win that prediction like the bishop
on g2 didn't move again in the game
this sure remained bad throughout well
it is a win for
uh team mike they are ahead one and a
half to a half we have some special news
happy birthday rex singfield today is
his birthday this gentleman who has done
so much to transform chess in the united
states today is a great celebration of
all that he has done and we are so
absolutely grateful
for his generosity
we are
again at this point one and a half
two a half
a mistake by fabi very uncharacteristic
he said he had already given up he
thought the game was already over so it
didn't matter but queen g6 would have
changed things and extraordinarily sharp
game to be sure
queen g6 this is one of the kind of
games that you hope that you could
analyze
deeply and really take a look at i'm
sure the players will be thinking about
it as well because it was such such an
entertaining affair we're gonna have two
more games shortly again score one and a
half to a half we'll be back
don't go away as we continue ultimate
moves 20-21
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and we are back to
ultimate moves 2021
it is
team rex versus team mike at the moment
team mike is winning one and a half to a
half the first game was a fighting draw
the second game decided by an
uncharacteristic mistake by one fabiano
caruana and that has given team mike the
lead we will see how they bounce back
in this next game and join us tomorrow
as we will begin chess nine lx better
known as chess 960 or fisher random
where the positions the players don't
know beforehand so preparation doesn't
matter at all it'll be very exciting as
all the players here will be playing
again tomorrow as well and for the next
three days
well we are going to start our next game
game three we have switch colors yet
again let's get right to that and start
that game this time mike with the white
pieces and rex with black
and
let's uh the players seem to be just
casually waiting the openings have gone
really well so far
all right we'll see whether they can
maintain that
opening accuracy
and at the moment there's been a couple
of unconventional moving with one hand
and hitting the clock with the other
i guess it's allowed
i don't think it's you're talking about
me
again i'm sure that should be allowed
but
here we go
and
all right
all right there we go they're back to
standard technique right there
now we see another fan cat out there we
did a quite interesting setup
and
now
and that's the fifth move
and here comes rashford
and rex has played his fifth move and
fabiano caruana enters the fray and a
quick c3
played by maxime
levon you guys are down in the match
how are you going to come back temporary
and we're generally a better team so
we're we're expected to give them some
chances
[Laughter]
you will see in this one
all right queen b3 hitting the pawn on
b7 and this is this is the second time
that maximum has gone pawn chasing and
the second time
that he's ignored the pawn it's the
second time maxim is getting a losing
position with white out of the opening
[Laughter]
which is becoming somewhat a beautiful
tradition
[Laughter]
you know you're good friends with maxine
you've told me you love when
you beat him i mean it's quite special
for you
i think uh yes uh
playing and uh seeing uh maxim
uh and especially you know
feeling that he understands how much
better i am than him it just makes me
happy
so far it doesn't seem as if he's
too radical no no he's uh he knows it so
that's the beauty
makes
your your good buddy here saying that
it's it's a special moment when he beats
you because it shows that
he's a better player than you are you
thought
well i think you know it's hard to
you know
get people to chase away their dreams so
i'll let him have this one
your position so far in this game
you've gotten some d4 openings
not normally
well i was
ready to play any position but what i
see is one night from black's
perspective that's not
doing any great job anytime soon
beautiful piece yeah
but we're still better
another complicated position bobby looks
like
you're getting some interesting games
from the amateur players
yeah this is this is a good position
well actually our games are kind of
interesting
specifically when we play we usually
i know
but still it's it's pretty symmetrical
and balanced
and what will happen in the future is
the pressure is the pressure on you guys
right now because you've got to tie them
in there
you need to play an aggressive game now
and score a result with the white pieces
sorry
i did this and this
isn't a bad result
but we have white next game so
that's also a chance to tie the match up
let's just keep the game complicated
yeah
okay
i don't need to just simplify everything
right
i can just keep some attention in the
game
[Laughter]
so how would you evaluate the future of
the bishop on december i'll just
[Laughter]
now be played
not much of an edge on the clock but
definitely a minute plus
for the moment try to correct his
previous move
no no don't worry don't worry
there is uh
there is no correcting here there's an
egypt there's a deep concept
backwards i believe sam shanklin said
that
but they go forward
right now
having said that you know by the time i
am there you know i might not have any
decisions
they're trashing your moves so far
no i thought i'm
i'm
here in a team of uh
colleagues that support my moves and
then
you know what evan i support your moves
i stand by your moves
not necessarily the moves
themselves yeah actually e6 is so deep
i'm still thinking the main idea behind
that
because the one says they're a much
better team yeah
now you understand i mean it takes 10 15
minutes and then you get it you're
talented
all right hikaru trying to figure out
the best path and it serves the head
with
h5 it's all because of the knight on a3
they had the repetition and they didn't
take it
no bishop g5
squid bishop f4 yeah
i thought
yes yes no you have a valid point
linear going into deep thought uh
which is not unusual for him
even in a blitz game
it's amazing that he manages to survive
and be so he's so good at it when he
gets into time pressure a lot
yeah i think he is
in his own games the balance works for
him of like leaving himself a minute and
then actually never making a mistake on
a minute in the next 25 moves but
in this particular format you're passing
on the minute to somebody else so
i don't know
i don't know how balanced this strategy
is
let's say so as he's still deep in
thought now down to
6 50 on the clock and uh we're about to
be down two minutes and his teammates
will have to take care of this
even rex doesn't like the petition if
you look at his faces very horrified
c5 explosive move allowing the knight to
get to the b5 square
gary's thoughts on this one
what do you think about the position
right now look it's now it's getting
sharper and sharper so we just we
probably winning with zero so the pawn
and d5
will be
doomed
uh but they try to organize an attack
inside so we'll see so it's like far by
white has a
very promising position but at least we
are we're in the game
so i don't know maybe now maybe what i
would do now maybe play a4 and then okay
just to keep my queens there that's one
option
what do you think about the potential of
white attack is it is it clear to you
that freight has anything it's not
that clear but you know that white will
have queen on g4 then potentially as
this is
still you know i still don't see how the
white rook goes to
to uh h1 but that's that's the plan so
little queen g4 take their bishop free
king h1 i don't know
it takes time but
how much blood can do
so since it's because it's a little bit
tight on twitch
yeah so let's do
very tricky while you're the queen
especially if your queen migrates to b5
okay but we still have to take the bomb
and then bishop goes on g7 and then
we'll see how
soon
you know he needs he needs a little bit
of time so probably you play e5 at one
point you know just to e5 bishop g5 and
then just
quench e5 bishop d5 and unblock my king
and then start bishop freaking g2
i'm
a little pessimistic about it
dangerous
and a loss here decides to match
just to hold the position and
what you did was
questionable
all right i'll let you figure out how to
defend this position
we've got some spillage happening on the
floor over here
i think this is a metaphorical 10.
e5
g4 bishop
right
you just
queen c3
i don't know if you can do it like this
bishop g7 rook h1 now
um
deep analysis that these two are
engaging in this is their version of
trash talking and they figure out what
it is to defend the position but
e4 and
it's probably mate so it's probably made
made in 10 like you said
maybe even more than ten what
something like that
one clean attacking house i don't think
it will happen
are we getting mate called right now
it looks like white has a very promising
position
yeah well this is my nightmare being
upon down and having a winning attack
because everyone knows i don't know how
to checkmate anybody i can only win
boring games but uh
i can do my best so we'll have to see uh
it depends a lot on what shaq does in
the next couple moves so he's sort of
gonna have to decide how i'm going to
attack for me and then we'll see if i
manage to screw it up or not but
uh
last time when i sat down with gary my
king was in huge trouble and now
maybe i have a chance to be on the other
side so i'll be [ __ ] attacking gary
caspar
yeah again i'm not a great attacker but
i will i'll do my best and we'll see
maybe i'll meet him
maybe you will all right well let's
these players and again gary's shaking
his head over here see gary
not happy at all
and the players are scattered all about
this does have a different feel from
last year
the crowd was here last time packed
around of course it's pandemic so we
don't have anybody
uh able to stand and watch as we had the
last time
to react and for the players to play up
to as well now e5 played quick bishop e7
on the board and white has made his
intentions very very clear that he's
going
to go straight for the throat he wants
to check mate each h-file is there the
dark square weaknesses
can the black king survive the attack
that's going to come straight at him
let's get into another group of players
who are
we got teammates and also one
maximum
outsider
listening in on these guys uh you're
feeling you feel like they're just
desperate i have my own opinions about
this position and
while there might be ways to put up some
resistance for black we all know where
this is going and the king of g8
and then
no it's not that bad
how many we're
you know we're creating chances
in order to create chances you need to
complicate things
some chances now they're arguing
otherwise they're saying black is okay
you know they cannot give what they want
foreign
in one more move it will be
gary and sam
and we will see and now bishop g5 has
been played chakra are getting up sam
sitting down
and the great gary kasparov waiting in
the wings as he knows his king is on
heavy fire he likes to be on the other
side
of this attack
and there goes peter
and sam said he's not a good attacker
will he be able to find the right way to
proceed right now
as it looks like the h file has been
shut down the damage on that side
has been mitigated
and the hope is for
black to be able to shut the attack
beat back the attack and then
somehow win that pawn on b5 which looks
isolated looks like he's gonna die
but also remember the two amateurs are
coming in
shortly and sam with only 220 on his
clock
5 55 for black so a big time edge as
well and we see a deep think right now
by
sam shanklin of mike's team
guys there's a big thing right now for
sam and he's down to only two minutes
left
on the clock
you just want to draw here despite being
three minutes up on the clock maybe four
minutes no i'm on the white side oh
you're the white side i forgot i i see
all the american players here somehow i
think i don't know but you you're on the
other side
so
do you feel
no
might get recruited
do you still feel as optimistic as
before maxime about your position with
white
i mean i am a poor frenchman but
uh i can say that our position has not
improved since my birth prediction so
this time my bold prediction might turn
out wrong suddenly
yeah made in 10 was a little premature
especially given the math situation yeah
of course
the being up again also rex promised we
he's gonna beat us
the next two match
but do you think that do you guys think
that rex and rex and mike are going to
repeat moves
someone will someone will deviate i
don't know who but someone
oh my gosh
rick h1 trade and gary now
trading off all the rooks killing the
attacking chances
bishop 86 and i believe only one more
move to go before
the real excitement starts
as we're going to see the two amateurs
go down and sam well aware of the clock
situation
trying to figure out what to do next
he's down to 115 he's left himself very
little time
to find a solution here as black is way
ahead 5 40 left on the clock and finally
samples between that four quickly and
there goes mike
and gary knows it's a responsible
decision right now as rex will sit down
next
is there enough of an attack here for
white
black take the pawn bravely
is now ahead by a pawn and the two
amateurs sit down gary that was a big
moment when you took the
pawn you gave you took the pawn and
you feel comfortable about giving rex
this position
okay fine no now now i'm more
comfortable
but look it's the it's i think i think
this is he had to basically repeat the
moves because i wasn't sure that i i i
thought i would probably take on g58
because i thought we had more time but i
was hesitant because i knew that his
next rex comes in so i wanted but right
now
just all he needs to survive
to survive this
you know august
and i think it should not be that
difficult hopefully put one before big
knight back b5
and then
and then we can do the rest
all right
very optimistic right now
and
in the meantime white is under a minute
51 seconds with black
team rex having five minutes on the
clock here up a pawn this could be the
combat game
and bishop f8 offering a trade more
trades to mario being up material
great retreating move
and bishop back to e2
interesting move be sure and there those
wrecks trading on
critical piece
and white's attack is dying
quickly
as more trades happen suddenly black is
in complete command
off the position with only 52 seconds
left this might get tough as rex's
next move
oh there's almost no bad news here in
fact that's white's attack always offers
more trades great systematic play by rex
incredible play rex you you uh you
defang that attack pretty effectively
thank you
and now we see maxine bashar the grav
and fabian and karyana come in white
with only 52 seconds and
the right kind of consolidation could
make this the comeback game force the
tiebreaker
in game four
and fabi decides there is no attack for
white and he goes right for it and
instantly bishop g4 ignoring
the b-pawn he can go down two pawns here
peter what's going on well we have we
have more pawns which is uh
important
but there's there's some counterplay i
thought we could have played more
conservatively previous move but yeah
we we're still in control yeah queen
eight yeah we're gonna make you defend
uh the only worry is that the king might
get active quite king but
the short demon thing yeah
too long
now also the take deepon is going to
cause some danger
bishop e6 has too many drawish i mean
but i don't know if that actually does
very much
i think if all else feels like fun i
don't know maybe yeah
kind of a weird position all right you
just treat it completely
good
and uh
sam yeah how are you feeling right now
yeah i wonder if i could have played
that phase better i mean it was sort of
under my watch that the pawn dropped off
but i thought the position was not great
and i should just start throwing stuff
towards the king as much as possible but
then the attack never really
materialized and here
uh i think i actually think b5 was not a
good move or maybe he can just go before
b3 but i was thinking that if the bishop
can come to d1 we should have counter
play but i think before b3 handles it so
yeah this uh this game didn't go as well
as i would have liked it seems like we
could have done better
all right down to
one minute and two seconds for mike's
team they
want to keep that lead but right now
it's going to be up to
players of blockage b4 b3 on the board
total domination it looks like how does
the squad make progress probably
queen a3 a nice blockading move
very nice
and that ties down
a lot of people
this last move
maybe he doesn't have a threat
like at some moment we'll take one of
those pawns and then the pawns will
start to roll on b2 or c3
do you say a night sacrifice is the way
to win at some point
the bishop has no
squares
like it can go on this diagonal but
because of the light square pawn chain
it can't ever influence anything on the
queen side yes so black at some point
just sacrifices it gets a4 a3 it's just
that's it
all right let's listen and levon looks
like he's trying to intimidate
you see it right see what because i
don't see
i don't know something ghosts
just like that
it shouldn't
it shouldn't be any good
maybe we should have repeated when you
have the chance
no no no no repetition i'm going to beat
you
slowly
and precisely okay this is mine
has occurred as fabiano said it would
and now
a huge threat of just
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is my first one yeah this is your
first first move
so it looks like the players
are not clear on
whose turn it was to move at the moment
but now can white muster up some kind of
perpetual
but it looks like this game might have
solidified someone
did
black blow this seems like it should be
a draw now yeah
what did you do wrong did you sacrifice
some pizzas
we're trying to figure out why he
couldn't have just taken on b2 after
queen e7 because i think there is no
perpetual i think lev may have kind of
trusted wesley about 27 a little bit too
much
all right this is a big missed
opportunity
is a supreme defender he's not
intimidated easily
and 51 seconds is
like a year to him
so it looks as though this game may end
in a draw and everyone's confused that
black should have been winning this
position but now it looks very very even
that's going to put a lot of pressure on
team rex to win the last game as they
are down one game in the match and the
time ticking down
to 1 11
evening out as
clearly linear is looking for some kind
of winning idea
playing queen e2 after much thought
a little confusion about whose turn it
was to me when shakaria sits down
and we see look
linear allowing his time to tick down
and he's actually now low on the clock
before they were ahead because black has
to be careful here and he's by the way
back to e4 and it looks like they're
repeating moves as peter sits down
rex is going to deliver the killing blow
you'll see
looks like they're going to try to last
until the amateurs but only 43 seconds
left before
and now an offer to trade
which cannot be accepted
because a deepon would promote
guys your thoughts right now
we were close
but now it's uh
i thought this i i completely forgot
queen of three quincy ii
missed that square
all right well gary about to sit down
makes him you guys look like you're in a
good situation in the match
i never doubted my team
i thought we would write it up but okay
we are saving some
you know suspense for the last game but
we won't know what we're going to win in
the end
all right do you know what's going to
win i i don't know who's going to win
the game bobby
he's saying he already knows who's going
to win this match uh we're saving the
suspense
until the last game you're feeling about
his confidence we're going to win the
match he knows that they're going to win
the match
i don't i don't i think so
i actually think we still have pretty
good chances to win this game
and the game has ended
in a draw
and that's that
they maintain a lead does
team
mike
mike how you feeling right now your team
is ahead with one game to go
i'm paying attention to the guys on my
team their morale seems to be high so
i'm following suit
rex you guys in a little bit of trouble
you know must win situation in the last
game in order to tie up the match well
that just clarifies it means we have to
win
so he's he's always on the water and his
his barges you know so he's just trying
to stay afloat you know what i
mean in the spirit of good sportsmanship
i'm prepared to offer you a draw in the
fourth game
all right that would obviously clinch
the match
no such luck all right right now team
mike leading
two games
uh drawn one game one we're gonna have
one last game to decide it all will team
rex be able to make the comeback here in
ultimate moves we'll decide
in just a few minutes we'll be right
back
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello again everyone it is time for the
deciding game game four
it is
currently a two to one score with team
mike leading over team rex will team rex
be able to make the ultimate comeback in
ultimate moves before that we should let
you know tomorrow it'll be very exciting
beginning to chess nine lx's these same
players will come back to play chess 960
or also known as fisher random
they won't know positions are coming at
them and they'll have to figure it out
as quickly as possible as we'll see some
wild and woolly chess positions and no
question about it lots of excitement
let's get started with game four right
now
and the clock has started and it is up
to team rex in a must-win
situation and they're repeating the
opening
from game two
should we get this game as clutch game
clutch game you want double the money
but there's no money on the line double
the points
double the points
[Music]
these guys want to make it really
exciting lavon what are your thoughts on
that i'm ready
we are white and uh we we had a great
position last time when we were playing
white so
i
i'm ready
to hear a white to move and win
white to move and win
uh that's a bit bold a prediction
sam uh
it seems like white is extremely
confident right now
what are your thoughts well it's early
in the game so anything can certainly
happen but i think opening has gone
better for us last time i just hated
this night on c7 like one bad piece
makes a bad position and we had this
horrible night and we won anyway of
course but uh no i mean here we have our
pieces are better placed then i think
we'll i won't have to jump in and have
as much pressure on my king
gotcha
linear
pressures on in this game
how to come up with the big result
i think the opening is
more or less what we need just a
complicated position um
i think we we have to try to to use our
chances here
where is the car
hey karu you guys are very good you guys
are doing well uh what do you think
about this this game
where you you just you just need a draw
to win the match i mean i think all the
games have been pretty good i think the
fact that rex and mike have gotten out
of the opening it's just been normal um
no one's made any huge blunders has made
this pretty exciting um
but i think yeah we're getting better
positions in general and i think i think
we're gonna win the match before before
rex and mike have to sit down again
thank you all right we see some exciting
breaking out let's listen to lavonne and
and wesley
i'm just a simple guy ah yeah i see
something i take it
made it very forceful for me so i don't
even have to think
but how do i take it that is the
question
is it takes 6 6
it should be something in order i
believe
simple
[Music]
yeah
or you can keep taking them
i can also play queen h5
which is also tempting
i play the barely a new favor
what does more time think i don't know
your options doesn't make them better
maxim i don't really play the sicilian
okay
okay finished
yeah i wasn't sure what was all this
yeah
the only point was that probably he
would play a four and bishop before we
would win
sorry what play again after queen h5 and
the hope was for f4 you know but
actually questions there's a queen eight
tag it might be fun i thought this
wasn't so sure
i was worried it would lead to some draw
sorry
um probably up there maybe magnus is
comparable but yeah
lavon is one of the best for sure
they seem to have been there for a while
as well the two of them okay this this
must be good
and it looks like he's played his fifth
move and he has to get up
tempting moment as the attack is brewing
lavon
you feel like you've done your duty a
lot of exchanges but an attack in the
position
i think
this was uh generally a good uh
way that uh fabiano played this g4 h3
which is ridiculous but it
caused
a closed maxim to
think that his position is much better
than it is in reality
he's saying that you kind of gave some
chances to white
well again i'm building the suspense
and why is our position bad also i i was
thinking at some point we could
psychically exchange player four and
just pretend we have compensation
yeah
this
is how you roll yeah
this is how he rolls so right now it is
up to lanier as
my
biggest concern is that we have no pla
no peace to awaken
so there's no great awakening because
all of our pieces are active already
have you heard have you heard this idea
the great awakening he keeps talking
about
i think it's a french thing
they're
eating so much and sleeping so they need
to awake
that's true
we take our food seriously
all right well there's going to be some
kind of serious
eating on this board as pieces
may hang at any moment but it looks like
f4 has finally been played shutting down
some of the lines to the black king
now despite having
extra pieces over there it doesn't look
like your attack is going very far right
now
i think
yeah
we're doing great i think yeah yeah
i can win some material if i want to
this is a
big tension filled game there's still
two players who will be playing two
grand master pairs who will be sitting
down
and this is a must-win game for the
white pieces
black must be feeling attention here
sam uh
how are you feeling right now
um i'm wondering if i'll get to play
this is not looking good so far but uh
you know maybe we can be more solid than
first glance uh did not like e5 but i
thought this was very impatient
it's the right idea but i think you
should wait a bit first and develop the
pieces before opening the center like
that and now
uh but yeah i survived the dangerous
position with kasparov attacking me last
time maybe i couldn't do it again but
this one looks much scarier
all right plus definitely a plus for
white
gary you guys need this win badly but it
does look good for you yeah but yeah it
looked a little better move ago it's of
queen h692 would be probably stronger so
just here to now probably 92 again the
only move
so but it's not as as effective so it's
the
yeah it's a period because we circling
692 i think we could put them on the
ropes
all right still still some chances
though look it's very sharp position so
it's uh
still having
plenty of fight but now it's probably
the size of the moment because if he
doesn't play 92 here and just then black
takes all initiative because the moment
black plays rook f5 and rg6 you know
well we're dude are you surprised by
some of the mistakes that have been
played bobby missed queen g6 lavon
played e6 92 missed here you ask the
wrong person about mistakes
[Laughter]
it's still relaxed when it just happens
all right
he's played the move maybe one move
later but still yeah yeah i wish he
would have played it earlier because
then it would be really bad for black
now
let's see what keep our reality
so
all right this one's under pressure
chakra
uh you you'll have to play this position
next right
how are you feeling about your position
right now okay i mean i think few moves
ago it was a bad position but now it's
okay i mean still we are fighting
fighting chess
indeed
everybody knows this is a big game in a
big moment there's five minutes and 36
seconds on the clock 7 43
for black
team mike
with hikaru defending his display knight
to g6 and made it very difficult for
lanier
who gets into time pressure looks like
he's getting into more time pressure
right now
what are you feeling peter
you guys had a great position but now it
looks like it's a bit of a tussle yeah
it's it's quite unclear now and
yeah time is time is also
slowly becoming a factor so
it probably will be quite complicated by
move 30 so uh
much will be decided sort of in in
mutual time trouble and possible 30 i
think
hopefully what do you feel about this
format it seems like it's popular with
the fans
uh players play against each other but
it's only done once a year it looks like
anywhere in the world do you think it
should be done more often
i think yeah i think it's enjoyable well
it's enjoyable to watch it's uh
fun to play playing they played in the
right spirit i think there should be
like a decent
ideally you would like a balance between
you know people try harding and people
having fun and uh
as long as you keep that balance it
should be yeah oh all right peter's off
his turn
bishop takes on v2 white one upon but
black is now one upon back the knights
are off the board
and certainly a sharp fight
but black needing a draw
more than anything
which will win the match we have two
very interesting
spectators in mike and rex who will be
coming in
in about nine moves
which seems the position will get to
those nine moves the way it looks right
now
the teams are congregating
pretty much as teams we see fabian alone
maxine the position was not looking
great before but it looks like you got
some chances i always have lots of trust
in my teammates you know to repair the
damage i had previously done so
you're doing completely fine
playing in this game you definitely need
to rely on your
teammates
he's just pirating what i exactly said a
second ago
all right black definitely making a
comeback right now
and lavon it's not looking great for
your team you need a win
we'll get there we'll get there i think
we have uh
you know we have advantage of two
bishops
an advantage of two rooks and a queen
and that's that's a good advantage
because there is a lot of pieces to play
for so
we do know the tension is going to build
when
the two interested amateurs sit down as
well
so
certainly an uncertain situation
i think now fabi
your feelings about
if you don't win this game
or you're not thinking about it
i think i think i'll live if we don't
win the game
but i'd prefer if we do
all right looks looks pretty solid right
now looks pretty even but the tension
will be about the clock as well as rex's
team is down to 3 20
5 as peter is looking for something to
do
not clear at all
how to get any kind of advantage and he
is struggling to find a move
talking with disgust what people were
trying in these games but he's been
thinking for you know
an overly long time
and he's finally moved with only 306 on
this clock black with almost seven
minutes
that's unusual to see a giant
four-minute lead
on the clock chakra can
leisurely
calculate variations right now how to
shut down
what is coming next is an enormous
pressure
on the white side peter still with three
moves to make forward
sam and gary kasparov come down again
we're eight moves away from the amateurs
coming in and that could throw
throw something strange into the apple
cart
yeah we're hearing some trash talking
from a different part of the crowd we're
trying [ __ ] memories because normally
you are just bombastic right we got to
put you four rooms away from the players
and now you're up here very calmly
analyzing the position discussing it
calmly with the players come on this is
a tough crowd
a tough crowd this is tony rich
executive the regular of the chess club
so tony
we're normally we have people here and
you know there's a big boisterous
atmosphere but today it's a bit more
sedation it is absolutely unfortunately
due to the covet policies here in st
louis we weren't allowed to have
spectators in person which is totally
the best part of this event i want to
hear their trash talking i want to hear
them mocking lavon when he gets up and
has to resign on his first move playing
or something like that so you know we're
going to make do but we're still happy
to celebrate rex's birthday with him
here today and have a nice fun event
absolutely it's quite a bit of fun and i
get joy bray who never wants to go on
camera watch this guys watch this choice
running joy can we get a word
there she goes you can never get drawn
camera okay it is the way it is well
let's get back to the action as
white is down to 303
on the clock
and uh
trying to figure out
what to do next is two more moves to
make and he's trying to keep the tension
high
in
and peter definitely hesitating right
now
over his moves as his clock is just
inexorably ticking down
one more move before sam and
gary kasparov sit down
and i think the players somehow feel a
little bit resigned
to the fact that it's an even game
wesley
it feels like you guys feel like this
game is pretty much drawn but at the
same time we know that the amateurs are
going to sit down anything can happen
yeah yeah we just need to wait and see
until they come
but uh today they haven't been making
any blunders i think mike's been playing
very well he only made one mistake the
entire day so i'm pretty pretty amazed
actually that is a very good observation
are we going to trash talk randy
singhfield when we see him next
yeah it seems like
yeah we don't need him
[Laughter]
oh wow
kicking the sun after of rex down
all right again one
two more moves for black one
for white
attention building as this is a critical
game
a win for white ties the match
will they be able to pull it off they're
in time pressure
and gary caspar are ready to sit down in
two moves
and then we'll see the amateurs sit down
so the tension is building as the clock
ticks
and takes and takes we will get to some
severe time pressure it looks like
to decide it all
fabia
why is this so taking chakra so along
um thinking of playing with the move
11 mentioned
which move
the sacrifice and
then create and
purely positional compensation
and instead he's decided to be super
passive and just defend the pawn
that that looks very very strong for
black because then bishop on e5 would
dominate the game
all right
some some chances now for white
what do you want
all right well e5 has certainly changed
the fabric at the time
situation as a time now with gary
sitting down with white and he's got
that intimidating look on shakriar as
sam now has to sit and survive
against one of the greatest attacking
players of all time
as gary tries to figure out what to do
this is a money game must win
for the white pieces for team rex and
gary trying to figure out what to do
here his time is now taking down it
bishop to g5
attacking to work on d8
and sam knows this is a critical moment
the next five moves
will set up
the game for the amateurs will they be
able
to maintain the tension and now rook to
g8
offering
a simple trade on f7
but how to win now
and there it is the trade has occurred
black's position somewhat compromised by
the pawn on e5 and gary moving quickly
three moves played by white only two
more before the amateurs sit down
that'll be the wild card
in this game and uh let's get some
thoughts as these players are
calculating furiously what happens next
they're quite close to just
losing that force
what we're doing now
well
what's the thought about this position
why you going to win
why
but
it will take some time
queen g6 play i think it's no or never
for you to win
but we don't know how we're going to do
it
better
structure we meaning black of course yes
we obviously attack against
the better pieces where are your better
pieces on the g5
okay
like that the the awakening bishop on g7
i mean it's still better that we show up
on g2 i mean we're coming to the second
is going to be awakened quite soon
what gary did looked completely stupid
but it has a point it's not so bad
up to h6
and 86 played
bishop
here we go now the amateurs come in at a
critical juncture
in the game will they be able to
maintain this position before the grand
masters sit down with 146 correct
207 for black the next five moves could
be it
huge amount of tension right now
deciding the match if
rex's team going with white pieces
can win the game they tie
the match
126 only on the clock
as white contemplates what to do next
still hasn't figured out what to do and
he has opted to trade
on g7 that's a big move
and after work takes
there is the threat of mate on g2 that
white will have to deal with
and he's down to only 102 left on the
clock and now he's under
a minute with four moves to play
and he's not seen
and he is not seeing the threat at all
the game can be won
instantly with queen takes on g2
that would be jack made
and if black
misses
the mate and sacks of peace out of the
blue
what is happening now is pure chaos
on the board he can just
take that piece and be winning
but his time is sticking down with 43
seconds left
and he's stopping to think
his racks 36 seconds and ticking down
will ricks just simply capture the
bishop and be winning
and he did not capture the bishop oh
kind of madness breaking out as the
players can't believe what's going on
they played such great chess until now
and suddenly they're playing some
wild moves
peter what can you say about what just
happened
it's
perhaps to be regretted
okay gamer's game is still very much on
let's go
where you have to give up all your
pieces man
this this is pure insanity
a mate missed a free piece missed and
the players are oblivious to what's
going on at the moment
what can you say about what just
happened
uh it happens played a lot of games
these things happen yeah it's very
normal i'm used to it that's pretty kind
of you yeah yeah well sometimes you miss
what pieces are on what squares and i
think you see a tactic and it feels like
brilliancy but it's not
all right well some
crazy moves missed and at least the game
is still going on
white is still
alive and now here's the last moves
being played
rex you could get up
with only nine seconds left on the clock
and now two pass pawns
for white he's not being mated it looks
like and it's just chaos
on the board
le mans i mean okay so madness just
happened but now it's even crazier yeah
yeah it's a pretty exciting game man
well we can only explain it that uh
our amateur players just got tired at
some point because it's tough to
maintain this level to follow it so but
now maybe we'll have a comeback i trust
in fabi
he's a he's a talented young lad and
with with pawns like this
i've seen him do wonders
all right again very little time on the
clock as the pressure is on
ten seconds remember there is a five
second increment
full minute lead on the clock
two pass spawns for white but can he
maintain the game as now
we see maxine going into
to deep thought in this position
peter yeah i think we're in with a shout
now white's got a chance absolutely yeah
yeah it would be bad if you guys don't
win on his birthday i mean that would be
tragic no you can't beat the guy on his
birthday i mean the last thing you want
to do in your birthday is play chess
but don't tell him that
i think we're gonna lose now
yeah we messed it up badly
probably the last move was a mistake
no it's good it's good
we should have a diaper
all right here we go
[Music]
now it's getting serious the chance is
there for white to suddenly come back
and win the game
and black trying to keep the time
advantage as he is 27 seconds to only
seven seconds
and the time is his worst you've seen so
far eight seconds to fourteen
and he has captured the bishop
and the like queen
and both sides now down to 12 seconds
each
another check
and another check and they will have to
change out very quickly as the five
moves have been played and here comes
the new players
and a check while he's sitting down as
they gained a little bit of time on the
clock
the zigzag maneuver by the queen has
left some time on the clock but what's
happening is both sides
are under heavy fire white unable to
just simplify the position
and he made a full series of moves but
has not made any real progress
as yet to
figure out what to do about black's
counter play which looks severe
now only seven seconds and we've seen
repetition of moves as peter's
jumped in and now play queen d7 chakra
are getting out of check will it be a
simple repetition and now a series of
checks on the other color so this is not
a repetition at all the king is going
back and forth but the white queen
has made multiple moves
and now that is the first repetition
and gary coming in
and now we're seeing another series of
repetitions
looks like
the next time this happens
and now queen of swords
check the sacrifice of his queen by gary
casparo
and sending amateurs
down and it is
35 seconds they built up a lot of time
with the increment
and rex is
oddly thinking about his move but he has
to take the queen and he has done so and
now two past pawns
gary gasparo changed the nature of the
game
by sacrificing
only temporarily the queen but now
they've got two pass pawns
and
a problem to solve and now rex can just
start marching his pawns down the board
if he finds oh he played a7 instead of
d6
he changed the whole game he should have
played d6 d7 and instead he played e7
and now that pawn has been firmly
blockaded
and white is in
big trouble now he can't make any real
progress and there goes mike
approaching the pawn with his king
and it looks like white is losing once
again you should have played d6 instead
of e7
but
that's now a very
easy winning position for black
you know anything could happen but now
this trade is going to make it super
easy
five moves played and it is basically
resignable as mike's team is going to
win
and they have resigned
congratulations the winning team team
mike has won ultimate moves 20 21.
mike
uh it was harem scarum there in that
game crazy but you guys managed to pull
it off it was uh it was absolutely
incredible i haven't been this uh
nervous since uh jennifer gave me her
last lesson
you you have defeated rex
you get bragging rights forever how does
that feel
it feels good and i know it's not
forever um because he comes back really
hard and really strong
all right rex
that was tough
i know you know it's not easy to to
interview after you're
not the winning side
that was a tough game
yes it was a tough game i congratulate
my opponents
they got lucky
[Laughter]
oh rex this was done on your birthday a
very
celebratory moment they don't know how
to celebrate
yeah being beaten on your birthday is
never fun it's been done to me before
for sure
is it uh was it hard to play on your
birthday no it wasn't
and you're feeling about this ultimate
move something to continue in the spirit
of having all these grand masters come
together and trash talk all the time
yeah i think it's wonderful
all right well that indeed
was very exciting there were some missed
moves it wasn't just rex's fault we saw
fabiano caruana also make a mistake
lavon made a mistake a couple more
mistakes but we have something very
exciting to share with you right now it
is rex's birthday and we have a cake
we have we've got a cake
rex it looks like we need a lot more
candles
maybe just a couple more candles
[Laughter]
happy birthday rex indeed
lighting the cake
and
seems to be a little bit of challenge on
the cake lighting side what is that
device that looks
i've never seen that before
i think good old matches would would
have definitely done it already but
this definitely looks
like it's working rex
everyone
everyone please before rex blows out the
candle
are we going to sing happy birthday to
rex all right let's do it one two three
[Applause]
all right
yeah you can't below it you got to fan
it rex you got to fan it let's see if he
can make it
great technique all right well that's it
for ultimate moves 2021 team mike did
win by score of three to one join us
tomorrow at 1 30 central for chess
nine lx's these same players will come
back find us a couple of amateurs to
compete
in chess 960 also known as fisher random
thanks for joining us everyone have a
great evening
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited